far cry 4 will bring you to cure on a
breathtaking perilous and wild region of
the Himalayas using a vast array of
weapons vehicles and animals you will
write your own story across an exotic
open-world landscape how do you want to
play Far Cry 4 from the comfort of your
home or from the highest mountain in the
world Ubisoft is selecting one
adventurous fan who will accompany a
team of experts to Everest to play Far
Cry 4 while hiking through the Himalayas
you could be a part of this historic
undertaking you'll be playing on a
one-of-a-kind gaming device this special
device has been built to withstand the
harsh conditions in the mlas will select
a winner and train him or her to climb
Everest and will supply them with the
equipment to be the first to play of
video games on Everest the first to play
in a device that can survive the
Himalayas so do you have what it takes
submit your video application today
showing this why you're the most
qualified for the track follow these
instructions when making your video and
you could be part of an adventure of a
lifetime
visit Far Cry game comm slash quest for
Everest for official rules and more
details